[Music]
so I'm really thrilled to have all of
you come to hear about research on cell
movements and I just want to get to know
my audience a little bit here so how
many of you are in the 12th grade you
can raise your hand there are a few up
there how many in the 11th grade
you tenth grade more ninth grade there
we go eighth grade Wow a lot of those
seventh grade Wow sixth grade
Wow fifth grade this is quite a group
here fourth grade Wow we have some
fourth graders here too
well I'm in the 70th grade I started I
started kindergarten 70 years ago and it
was so much fun I'm still going to
classes and reading and learning and
having a lot of fun and hopefully you'll
have a lot of fun during your life
stained in tuned with exciting things in
science another field so today I'm gonna
talk about cells and how they move over
here so let me tell you how I got
started on this so when I was in high
school we had a demonstration in our
biology class of an amoeba this very
kind of an amoeba it's pretty darn big
as cells go this is one millimeter
across here so you could just barely see
this thing with the naked eye and they
move beautifully as you can see in this
movie you can see that the the cytoplasm
the interior of the cell is flowing
toward the front here and pushing these
protrusions at the front which are
called pseudopods I'm going to stay away
from most of the fancy names we have for
things in biology but pushing forward
the front of the cell and I thought this
was really cool and whoops back up and
so having seen this in biology class I
was curious about what was going on and
it turned out that nothing was known
about the molecules that made the cell
move zero when I was in high school so
then I went on to college and then and
medical school and while I was there I
learned about
kinds of cells that move including cells
in our own body so this cell right here
is that called a white blood cell these
other cells the round ones are called
red blood cells that's what makes your
blood red carries the oxygen in your
blood you probably know that
and what these white blood cells are
doing are looking for bacteria that
might have gotten into your body through
a cut or a wound and they're gobbling
them up and removing them and protecting
us all from bacterial infections so
let's take a look at this cell moving so
it's got a big name over here which we
won't worry about but this is the white
blood cell and these are red blood cells
over here that carry the oxygen in the
blood and there's a little bacteria over
there now that the object is that this
white blood cell has to try to catch the
bacteria but it's getting pushed around
here so it has to navigate very
precisely to keep up with that little
bacteria wherever it's going
and whoops have made a wrong turn there
turns back to the north and eventually
right over here
it catches up with it and takes it
inside and breaks it down and that's
what protects you from infections so
this was very cool but even when I was
in college look even when I was in
college we still knew nothing about the
molecules that make make cells like this
move in medical school I read a paper by
some English scientists who claimed you
could take the guts out of the cell the
cytoplasm and look at it in a microscope
and they claimed to you it would move
around outside of the living cell that
was pretty amazing and it turned out
that other scientists were unable to
reproduce this result so people didn't
actually believe this but I said if
that's true this would be a great way to
study how cells move so I set out to
reproduce this experiment when I was a
medical student it took me 11 tries to
get it to work each one took about a
week but finally on the
try I got it to work and then it worked
every time after that so these guys were
right so I want to show you what we did
so this is the the Gups of the cell the
cytoplasm over here they're little
particles that are in normally in the
cytoplasm of cell this is the membrane
that would normally be around the cell
but we broke the cell open and so I'll
start up this movie and you can see what
happens if you look sharp Li the little
particles are sort of jiggling around
like they would at a particles in in a
glass of water this is the membrane over
here so we could remove the membranes
like that now we just have the guts of
the cell the cytoplasm and if you look
at it there's some jiggling around but
it's really not very impressive and if
this is all the time that the other
scientists looked at this is no wonder
they thought it didn't work but we were
patient and after a while you could
start seeing things happen that couldn't
just happen by the thermal motion in the
sample so like the whole specimens
moving around here on the slide this is
exciting you have to run out the hall
and grab somebody to come in and look at
this because this is amazing because
this is outside the cell look at all
these fantastic movie movements and they
get even more elaborate here
and I took these specimens and I looked
at them in a very powerful microscope
called an electron microscope and I
observed that they contained lots of
filaments which you can see their little
lines here and there are more little
lines here and there there were some
thicker filaments as well and that of
course reminded us of the kind of thing
you see in muscle which is the was the
best characterized system of movement
that we knew about at the time and in
muscle there are some fictional elements
and thin filaments so we thought wow
maybe amoebas and human white blood
cells are moving around using the same
molecule as his muscle so one day the
department chairman over here came in to
see me he was a very nice fellow was
very supportive in my career but he
looked at my pictures and he said nice
micrographs but do you really believe
that amoebas have actin and myosin like
muscle and sort of laughs and left the
room okay this was very intimidating I
must say because just like everybody
else nobody believed that this would
this could be possible but it turned out
that was the explanation for how cells
move and so now I've got a question for
you if you had done these experiments
how would you make progress in trying to
understand the machinery that actually
makes the cell move if you want to set
up your lab at this point what kind of
questions would you ask here's my first
answer
yeah you asked it's actually the right
question that is how does it work okay
that would be the big question but let's
say you set out to find out how it
worked and you didn't know anything
about how it worked what what were some
of the things you might go hunting for
what would you try to find anybody else
that was a good answer let's see what
somebody else can help me out here well
if you had a watch you're trying to
figure out how an old fashioned watch
you know works you'd probably look
inside that watch and take a look at all
the parts okay so that would be the
first thing on my list to find the parts
that make the system work and then what
would be the next thing if you had all
the parts of a watch what would you do
exactly okay the second thing on the
list would be to find out how all the
parts interact with each other and then
you could do some experiments for
example you could put your watch back
together your clock back together and
leave out one of the parts and see what
happened and maybe it wouldn't work so
well or you could try to come up with a
theory a mathematical theory for how it
worked and we do actually all those
things in biology so you did a great job
you or you would have been on the right
track here so let me show you a little
diagram of how this works so this is a
strategy that people use have been using
for about a hundred years to figure out
how things work in biology and the first
thing is you need a good biological
question so you guys know my biological
question is how does the cell move
second thing but you guys figure it out
you have to find the molecules the five
but the parts that make the cell move
okay and then there are three different
kinds of experiments you can do one
involves physics and that is to
determine the structure of all of the
molecules and what you really want to
know is where all the atoms in these
molecules are located and so that
requires some physical methods just like
your a clock you took apart you'd want
to understand
size and shape of all the parts in the
clock second thing is to do some
chemistry over here on the right that is
to characterize as you've correctly
pointed out you've got to figure out how
all the parts are interacting with each
other and you can do chemistry
experiments to understand that and then
of course you want to look in the cell
they find out what the molecules are
doing in the cell and when I first
started doing this work 50 years ago we
didn't have any way of doing that but
I'm going to show you a way that we can
follow the individual parts of the
Machine inside of a living cell and if
you have these three things structures
of the molecule something information
about interaction since a understanding
of how they're moving around in the cell
and you can come up with an idea about
what's going on in a way of testing your
idea is to make a mathematical model to
test your ideas with a computer
simulation and you say you run your
computer simulation here and look to see
what whether you could reproduce what
you see in the cell now what usually
happens and I'll illustrate that in my
talk is that your computer simulation
doesn't work okay there's something
wrong and then that is that means you've
really made some progress that tells you
you're missing something and you have to
go looking to find out what's missing so
you can go up here and find some more
molecules or do some more chemistry and
make better mathematical models and you
go around this loop here hopefully
getting closer and closer over time to a
correct description of how the whole
thing works so that's the big strategy
that people use in biology there's a
little physics a little chemistry a
little math a little computer science
and at the end of the day hopefully we
have an understanding of how things work
that makes sense to everybody
a little louder oh goodness
I'll try I've got the sound system
turned up high but I don't have a strong
voice okay so we have to find some
molecules and the most important
molecule in our system that I'm talking
about here is a protein called actin
over here I won't go into the any of the
details but the structure is based on
physics research where we can figure out
where all the atoms are in this protein
this is said to be the second most
abundant protein on the earth it's
probably the second or third most
abundant protein in your body and what
it does is it spontaneously assembles
into filaments and so the next slide
shows a growing actin filament this is a
filament over here we're looking at it
in a microscope a light microscope where
we can make movies and we're going to
add some more actin molecules and see
what happens now look close and I ask
you what you see so this is speeded up a
little bit and you can see the filament
growing and over time some more
filaments are dropping onto the surface
of the microscope slide but which end is
growing faster their green end to the
red end the green end so that one end
grows much faster than the other so why
is that well we did a lot of
biochemistry experiments and we measure
the rates of a lot of reactions and the
reactions over on this end which is the
green end are much faster than the
reactions over on the other end which is
the red end and that explains why the
filaments grow fast in one direction and
slowly in the other direction okay and
those numbers there's though quite a few
numbers up there there are 10 numbers up
there which described the rates of all
the chemical reactions and those numbers
are the foundation
for everything we know about how the
system works I'm not going to tell you
anything about these numbers but I just
want you to understand that having these
numbers is give you some really
fundamental information about this how
the system works and it would be built
into all the mathematical models now
even if you just had some of those
action molecules in a test-tube and you
added the kind of salt that you find in
in cells those filaments would all
polymerize in a few seconds into a big
tangled mess and they wouldn't do
anything so the cell has to control this
polymerization reaction and to do so
there are over 50 different kinds of
proteins in cells that regulate each
step in the assembly of these filaments
here we can see a filament and you can
see actin subunits gonna add to the two
ends there are some proteins that block
one of the ends over here there are
other proteins like this blue one that
cross length the filaments into a
network so there's the network is stiff
there are other proteins that break the
actin filaments up into little bits and
many more and this combination of
proteins and cells make sure that the
filaments polymerized only where the
cell needs to move forward now one of
these proteins down here this green one
called the ARP 2 3 complex discovered by
one of my students 25 years ago is
really important for the system because
it allows these filaments to make
branches so let's take a look at that so
here is the structure of that ARP 2 3
complex you can see there are seven
different colors because there are seven
different proteins making up this this
structure two of these proteins the
orange one and the red one are similar
to actin and it turns out that they are
the first two molecules in the branch
that's going to grow off the existing
filament this is a little 3d
representation of the complex here you
can see all the pretty colors the blue
subunits are holding the
to act on related proteins together over
here and there's some other subunits
that help it attach to the site of an
actin filament so let's see what happens
if we take some of those actin filaments
if you already saw a growing in the
light microscope
micro microscope here they are there's
one there's another one over there and
there and now we're gonna add some up to
three complex and actin molecules and
see what happens what do you think is
gonna happen we're gonna get branches
okay good here we go we'll see whether
you're right look at that so you can
actually see the branches forming right
before your eyes by taking the purified
molecules and putting them together to
reproduce these reactions to take place
in the cell that's a very important
strategy that people use in biology is
to find the molecules and then put them
together and get them to reproduce
something that they've observed in a
cell okay that's part of this overall
strategy so this is speeded up so it we
don't have to sit here all morning to
watch it but now we want to take a look
at these molecules in the cell that's a
little more complicated and as I said
what I got started there was no way to
do this but unfortunately in the last 20
years methods have been developed to put
some little beacons I'll call them on
the protein molecules and cells these
little beacons glow in the dark so you
can actually see where they are in the
cell and if they're attached to the
protein you're interested in then you
can follow it around inside the cell so
this is amazing so I'm going to show you
a little so-called molecular biology
about how you do this so this is a piece
of DNA here just a little teeny tiny
piece of the DNA you might have in your
cells and the red thing here is our is
the piece of DNA that's going to
determine the structure of the protein
that you're interested in okay and then
here's another little piece of DNA over
here
the right that doesn't have anything to
do with your protein now what we want to
do is attach this little
glow-in-the-dark protein to the red
proteins so what you do is in the lab
you make a piece of DNA that's got a
little piece of the red gene up here and
a little piece of the blue gene up here
and in between you put your the code
from the protein that glows in the dark
which is called GFP okay and then
something miraculous happens you put
this into the cell and this little piece
of DNA gets inserted into the gene up
here so now you've got the green glow in
the dark protein like there's some seats
up there you guys want to go find a seat
there's two seats right there okay they
seem to be happy okay no now now we've
got our red protein of interest with
this little green glow-in-the-dark
protein attached to one end so that's
super fantastic so now we can look in
the cell and or we can label up a
certain protein so here's the ARB two
three complex again and we can put put
for example this glow-in-the-dark
protein on one of these subunits a gold
one in this case okay now we can look in
the cell and see where that glow in that
art protein is located and that'll tell
us where the arc two three complex is so
here is a pair of micrographs of the
same cell this is just a regular
micrograph of the cell you can see the
edge of the cell right here and this is
a micrograph showing where the glowing
protein is located it's a little bright
in this room I don't really have any
control over that let's see
I'll there I can't tell what's gonna
happen well here we go oh that's way too
bright I made it worse oh my gosh this
was really dangerous well okay now you
can see better but you're in the dark
I'm sorry okay
so here we've got our kids this happens
to be a cancer cell over here and here
you can see that a glow-in-the-dark
picture and what you see is right around
the edge of the cell there's a bright
region and that shows you where the ARP
2 3 complex is located in the cell this
is actually a movie so we can play this
movie which is speeded up 150 times and
you can see that our protein of interest
are up to three complex states right at
the leading edge of the cell it's the
cells moving along I never thought in my
life I'd ever see anything like this
this was like a dream come true you can
follow your molecules around inside of a
living cell now you can also look at
these cells in the electron microscope
and the light microscope up at the top
or some pictures taking a light
microscope they're taken at five-second
intervals so the cells started out here
and then it moved there and they're
there over a period of about 20 seconds
you can see it's moving up here toward
the upper-right this is a picture
showing where the actin molecules are
located in the cell they're yellow and
then it's possible to prepare these
cells where you've taken off the cell
membrane and you can look inside the
cell and an electron microscope and in
this part of the cell up at the very
front you can see this fantastic array
of filaments those are each one of these
an actin filament like the ones you've
been learning about so far and what was
discovered by our friends about twenty
years ago was that these filaments right
up with the leading edge of the cell are
all part of a branch network and there
are up to three complexes which is
located there is responsible for making
all these branches
so let's think about what what must be
happening here these little filaments
are growing and somehow they're pushing
the cell forward so here is a cartoon
coming up
proposing how these branching growing
actin filaments can make the cell move
there's a lot of stuff on this diagram
but let's just focus at the top part of
the diagram this gray box up here shows
the membrane around the cell so that's
that's what's getting pushed and in the
cytoplasm is you just saw from the
electron micrographs there's some
network of these actin filaments and
they're all part of our branch network
and what happens is that the green thing
which is the ARP 2 3 complex lands on
our old actin filament and starts up a
new branch which grows and as the actin
molecules add to the tip of that
filament they actually produce force
they produce a lot of force as they're
growing and they push against the inside
of the membrane so let me give you an
analogy for how this would work so
imagine a bush a bush in the springtime
and of course it's got some branches on
it already
but in the springtime what happens new
branches start forming off of every one
of the branches in the book the bush and
if you put a net over the top of the
bush what would happen to the net in the
spring time as the new branches were
forming what that
well push against the net okay so you've
got this bush with all these little
twigs that are growing and what would
happen it would push on the net that's
exactly what happens in yourselves so
for example this process is responsible
for connecting all the cells in your
brain by growing out the front end of
the nerve cells until they find where
they're going and in your brain you have
1 million miles of these connections
that have all been produced by these
chemical reactions so how about that
you're a whole computer got wired up by
polymerizing filaments which are gonna
push the front end of the cell around
until it finds out where it's should be
connected how about that now how could
you test this well one thing you could
do would be to remove one piece at a
time as I said we could do with our
clock example earlier so you could
remove one of these proteins like you
could remove the green r23 complex and
see what happens so what do you suppose
happens if you remove the are up to
three complex anybody it stops branching
I'm sure everybody else thought of the
same thing okay thank you for answering
though it stops branching and what does
this do this really slows down cell
movements because the branching is
what's producing new generations of
filaments that are actually producing
the force to make the cell move or he
could remove any one of the other these
proteins and find the consequences and I
assure you that every one of them on
this cartoon is important and something
bad happens if you remove any one of
these proteins so that's one test so
another test you could do would be to
run a computer simulation of this and
that's actually in some ways the best
test because it's impossible I'll get to
you in just a second it's impossible
it's impossible for the human mind even
somebody who knows a lot about this to
really understand how this thing works
you just your brain isn't good enough to
figure out how it would actually work
and whether your
ideas are correct but you could test
your ideas by making a mathematical
model and running a simulation in a
computer and see whether it comes out
the way you think yes yeah he asked
whether the different proteins can speed
up or slow down the cell movements now
all these contribute here to the
speeding things up and so if you get rid
of any one of them it slows it down okay
sometimes it's a little indirect I
didn't show you the details but these
little little molecules and the
filaments have to recycle like this so
if you slow down the recycling you run
out of molecules to make the filaments
grow and things slow down for example
great question thank you this woman
wants to know how the cell knows where
to go and I didn't explain that but now
that you ask it happens to be on this
diagram up here this blue thing is a
molecule in the membrane of the cell
that's can react with for example
molecules that are coming from the
bacteria and if it reacts with the
molecules coming from the bacteria it
actually sets up a whole pathway that
promotes the formation of these branches
and we know each of the reactions along
that pathway okay and that's how the
things steers it's the cells looking for
chemical signals coming from the
environment and it steers in the
direction of things that it likes it
runs away from things that it doesn't
like by interactions with these
molecules in the membrane everybody get
that that was a great question many many
of my friends have spent years figuring
out the answer to that question which I
could give you in 30 seconds okay let's
let's look at a mathematical model now
to make a mathematical model you need
some biochemical and biophysical
information you need to make some
measurements on live cells and you saw
how to do that now and then you can take
that information and make a mathematical
model you just write down all the
reactions
that you think are responsible for the
activity you're observing and then you
use a computer to simulate the process
and this is actually the first
mathematical model of cell movement that
actually worked by some of my friends
and this is an outline to the cell over
here and inside this imaginary cell they
put all those reactions I had on the
previous slide and use the
concentrations we measured in cells and
the rates of the reactions we measured
in the test tube and just turned on all
the reactions to see what would happen
now the cell actually moves this
imaginary cell actually moves and if we
if they just let it go and run off the
slide so what they've done is kept the
cell in one place and they're going to
move the the background so that you can
see it moving by looking at the
background moving so here we go this is
very cool so here's our imaginary cell
moving along you can see it's moving and
it turns out that the mathematical model
produces enough force to move the cell
at exactly the rate that's observed with
live cells in the lab so this is truly
amazing you do all this biochemistry and
physics and math and the darn thing
works this is great okay so that's this
this full strategy where you start out
where you find molecules you
characterize the individual molecules
make measurements and cells and then you
put them all back together and see
whether your machine actually works and
in this case it worked great so any
questions about this before I go on to
something else I hope you're somewhat
amazed that you can use chemistry and
physics and math to understand some
complicated biological process yes why
are they moving that's that's them
that's the the floor it's like the floor
of the cell is sitting on the cell is
actually moving in this simulation but
in order that it doesn't run off the
slide they've let the the floor move
that the the floor is moving so
we can keep the cell in the middle of
the picture okay
oh that's a great question she wants to
know how you take this whole thing apart
and it turns out it automatically
disassembles itself you make the
filaments and branches but then the the
actin filaments have a little timer
built into them so they automatically
age and automatically disassemble pretty
fast in about 10 seconds so they push
and then they go away and then you use
all of that all those molecules to make
new filaments to move up the next
distance oh I don't know this is just
the coordinate system in their computer
simulation I was afraid this was gonna
be a little confusing hopefully you got
the idea that the cell was moving in the
background which would normally be
stationary has to be moved so you can
keep your eye on the cell okay those are
good questions let me tell you about
something else in the time we have left
but timing times good and that's that's
about how cells divide this is another
very fundamental type of cell movements
so so each of you started out as an egg
cell for mom and a sperm cell from dad
and they got together to make a one cell
embryo and then after that the cell
divided in two and then you were a two
cell embryo and then you then those all
those cells divided into again and then
you were a floor or cell embryo and if
you just keep on repeating this 38 times
what do you get a kid okay
so that's that killed got a trillion
cells in it do you have any idea how big
a trillion is you know if you started
counting right now one two three four
and so on how long would it take you to
count to a trillion it's counting I take
over do you know Oh much more than your
life much more than your life getting
getting to getting to a billion would
take you most of your life okay so this
would take you know many decades how
fast you speak if it went really fast if
you were really fast you might get up to
a few billion but you wouldn't get to a
trillion in your lifetime okay so I'm
just add to tell any of this because
trillions a big number but it only takes
38 rounds of cell division to get a
trillion cells to make a human beat how
about that okay so how does this work
this is another kind of cell movement
and here we have an example of an egg
cell happens to be from a sea urchin but
your cells would look about the same and
in this movie you'll have a chance to
see the cell going through the first
round of cell division like that so I
saw that when I was in high school too
and I thought that was really cool and
and but nothing was known about this
either nobody knew any of the molecules
that were responsible for this amazing
event so by the time I was a junior
faculty member in the 1970s one of my
friends discovered there was a band of
actin filaments which are usually yellow
color here so you're familiar with that
and we discovered that there were motor
proteins in this band of actin filaments
and that they together were likely to be
responsible for the formation of that
cleavage furrow which you saw over there
so here are the actin filaments and here
are the motors so I'm going to attempt
to turn the lights back on here so I can
explain about motors
something's happening that's not quite
enough okay great now I have a volunteer
right here right here who's gonna help
me explain about motors I want to thank
her very much what's your name Latoya
okay she's gonna help me explain about
motors so hang on to that we're gonna
play tug-of-war here so she she's she's
anchored over there someplace and I'm
and this is an actin filament it's red
this time you said a yellow it's also
much floppier that it really is it's
actually about as stiff of steel so it
wouldn't be flopping like this but I'm
gonna demonstrate what a motor can do
and I'm the motor my hands of the motor
and what the motor does is a grab onto
the actin filaments and it pulls and it
pulls and it pulls and if I pull hard
enough I can move you I think there you
go okay so that's how these motor
proteins work and I won't go into any
more details of how they work they burn
some chemical fuel and they produce
forces on the filaments so the idea here
is that these motor proteins motor
proteins sorry about turning the lights
off again here whoops there we go but I
think we're going to need you the motor
proteins are pulling on the the actin
filaments which are attached to the
membrane and that's going to pull on the
membrane to make the cleavage furrow
just to remind you let me show you the
cleavage furrow happening over here
again mmm
okay now that you know there's a bundle
of filaments around the equator of the
cell there and their motors pulling on
them you can imagine how that would
cause the cell to change shape okay now
you can do all the same things and in
this case you've got to find the
molecules you got to do some
biochemistry and biophysics in this case
it was very tough to find the molecules
in the case of cell motility there's
only about a dozen really important
proteins and biochemist like ourselves
found all of those proteins by doing
biochemistry experiments
in this case it was really hard to find
all the molecules because they're more
than ten times more protein molecules
involved with cell division than with
cell motility you never want to guess
that because this looks simpler than
cell motility and so who found the
molecules it was people doing genetics
genetics making damage to the genes and
finding out which of those damaged genes
were required for the cell to divide
into and the best organism for doing
that were these little yeast cells which
you can see here they're shaped like I
could chew in a second
they're shaped like little sausages like
a little hot dog and their butyl for for
doing genetics experiments and other
people in the field founded more than
150 genes and therefore more than 150
proteins were required for cell
movements I had a question over here you
still have a question that's a stage
called cytokinesis okay I'm trying to
leave out all the big words but maybe
you've heard that word someplace okay
yeah you heard about that last year okay
you guys are cool there's some younger
kids here who wouldn't know what that
meant so I left that out okay I'm trying
to avoid the big words okay so so the
geneticists found the molecules and
biochemists and biophysicist studied the
structure of the molecules and how they
interact with each other the usual
things and then we wanted to follow
these molecules around in living cells
so we could attach our glow-in-the-dark
protein over here to the end of one of
our molecules this happens to be the
motor that's going to pull on the actin
filaments and we can look in the cell
and find out where it's located and for
most of the life of the cell it's spread
throughout the cytoplasm that's in these
three cells which I'm circling here in
some cells you can see that there of the
oh I should point something out here I
was just about to take for granted in
all the previous pictures the
glow-in-the-dark protein showed up white
against a black background in this
picture I'm sorry we've reversed
the thing so that the glow that our
proteins are black here against a white
background okay so at a certain stage in
the life of the cell then the about half
of the black protein ends up in these
little spots which we call nodes and
then the nodes form a band like this and
there's a beautifully formed futur band
after a little delay the band starts to
constrict and it gets smaller and
smaller and then all the protein goes
back in the cytoplasm of the cell to the
rest of the cell cycle so this is a
movie it speeded up about 800 times so
we won't be here all night
looking at this thing and it's it
corresponds to about three hours in the
life of these cells so take a look at
these two cells right there they're very
nice as we turn on the movie and you can
see these events playing out first their
nodes then there's a beautiful ring the
ring constricts and then the protein
goes back in the cytoplasm so nodes ring
constriction back in the cytoplasm
everybody see that and every single
cells doing the same thing but they do
it at different times they're not all
synchronized so if you looked at any one
of these cells they're going to go
through the same process diffuse
distribution nodes rings constriction
back in the cytoplasm so we use movies
like this to figure out the timing of
the events and in the middle you can see
cartoons
here are some nodes in red there's a
ring in red and then you can see the
ring constricting just like you saw in
the movie that look like a movie okay
good and here's the timing these nodes
show up about an hour before the ring
forms and then the ring forms and
constricts over about a period of
another hour so the whole thing takes
about two hours in the life of the cell
and then we used our glow-in-the-dark
proteins to find out when our favorite
proteins that we knew were responsible
for this process showed up at the scene
of the crime and over here on the right
is a diagram showing when the different
proteins show up for example the action
filaments show up
here at about times zero the motor
protein actually shows up before the the
actin and they get together in this ring
as a delay while the ring the tours and
then the ring constricts over here so
now we knew sort of the the the rules
though that the the cell was following
we know the molecules that are involved
in the process let's see whether we can
figure out how this thing actually works
which is the question you guys asked at
the beginning so we set out to learn
enough about each one of these steps
like that arrow right there
it's the formation of the ring by the
nodes converting into a ring so we took
a close look at that and we'll take a
look close look at it here so we had
this idea based on the properties of the
protein molecules about how this worked
so this is a little sketch of what a
node looks like from the top here's
another another and another and here's a
view of a node from the side these long
skinny things of the motors there one
end is attached to the inside of the
cell membrane right over here and the
other end is dangling down in the in the
cytoplasm of the cell there's a little a
little pink protein in here and it grows
actin filaments they go off to the side
they don't have any idea where they're
going they just grow and if they have so
there's an elongated actin filament up
there and if it happens to get close to
another node then the motor is over here
going to bind on to it and then they're
gonna try to walk along that actin
filament just like we were doing in our
demonstration okay and the idea was that
the motors would pull on the filaments
and maybe they would just pull all the
nodes together to make a nice rings
that sound like cool idea the reviewers
of our paper thought that was a great
idea the only trouble is that it doesn't
actually work so how do we find out that
it didn't actually work well we do our
usual thing make a mathematical model
and run a computer simulation so here's
the model there's one node growing two
actin filaments we know there's two of
those pink things in their growing actin
filaments
and this one happened to get close to
another node so it gets captured over
here and then the motors produce force
that's F force pulling like we did in
our demo here and so we I did a
simulation of that here's the middle of
the cell here and we're gonna open it up
so here here's the middle of the cell
we're gonna open it up like that so in
this picture here you're looking at the
inside of the cell membrane and there's
about 70 little red dots those are the
little nodes and they're growing green
actin filaments but you can just barely
see here so then we run this in a
computer to see what happens and we
wonder how is it gonna turn out so
here's what happened over a period of
ten minutes 600 seconds we don't get a
beautiful contractile ring what happens
is we get ugly clumps of nodes okay see
I'm looking um over here there big
clumps of nodes what you want is a nice
continuous ring so this is bad so but
that told us we're missing something
so we've got to go back and find out
what we're missing so we have got to go
back and take a closer look at the cell
so we had made better micrographs and
here's a 3d reconstruction of the cell
turning around you can see all those
nodes there in the middle you can see a
movie
now the glow-in-the-dark proteins are
white you can see the motor protein
accumulating in these nodes over time
it's speeded up 15-fold and before the
actin filament start to polymerize they
don't move they just sit there but after
the actin filaments start to flow
mirai's then fantastically the nodes
start moving around but they don't just
collapse into a ring instead they're
going to every which direction sometimes
in the wrong direction and they don't
move continuously they start and stop
and this start and stop movement was our
clue to understanding what we were
missing now it seems to take a long time
but eventually all these nodes are going
to end up in this band which is part of
the Ring
so I'll be patient here and let the last
few ones get there and eventually every
single cell makes a perfect ring as you
can see right there okay so we had to
add something to our mathematical model
and here it is that is that the
connections between the nodes break they
break about every 20 seconds and we
discover the FIR and characterize the
protein that makes the breaks and we if
we add that reaction to our simulation
we have another simulation at the bottom
here this is the equator of the cell
we're gonna open it up like that so once
again we're looking at the inside of the
membrane and the cell in the computer
this is connected to that over there and
we're going to turn on these reactions
up here keep your eye on that node right
there it does great things and when we
turn on the reactions you can see that
the node moves in this direction but
then it stops right there because that
the connections got broken but then it
moved there the connections got broken
again and then eventually it gets
reconnected and it goes in this little
cluster and if you run the computer
simulations like this which is pretty
fast you can do this in a few minutes
and your computer this extremely simple
model up at the top here makes a perfect
contractile ring every single time never
fails
and even more amazing it makes it in the
amount of time that the cell takes to
make a contractile ring so this gives us
confidence that we're on the right track
we can also look at the constriction of
the contractile ring down here this is
what we see in the cell we can make a
model of that that has actin filaments
which are gray up here and the motors
are shown in orange and here's a
simulation of that once again the orange
of the motors and the Blues are the
anchors for the actin filaments you can
see that the actin filaments are growing
some of them go off to the side and
they're useless but a few of them get
captured by the motors here and that's
this line of gray and green down the
middle
and the simulation showed amazingly
enough this structure assembles itself
you don't need to have a little engineer
in there telling it what the double
molecule what to do you just put them in
the right place turn on their activities
and they assemble a contractile ring
perhaps even more amazing this computed
contractile ring here produces the same
amount of force that we measured in
cells so once again although these are
very complicated processes involving
thousands of molecules there's 200,000
actin molecules in this ring 15,000
motor proteins the simulation show that
our very simple hypothesis for how it
works actually reproduces what we see at
live cells so as I've described here and
both of my examples of cell motility and
cell division you do some biochemistry
and biophysics and make some
quantitative measurements and cells come
up with a mathematical model and
simulate that on the computer to find
out whether your ideas are correct or
false I showed you examples in both
cases where our ideas were not correct
and where the computer simulation showed
us we were wrong but showed us how we're
to move forward to get closer to the
truth and this is the example I showed
you for for cell division now so why is
this important for all of you in the
audience here so one reason is that
cancer is a very scary disease I had it
when I was 45 years old so thank
goodness Here I am 30 years later and
it's scary because what happens is that
the cell division that gets out of
control so damage to genes controlling
cell division allow the cancer cells to
grow inappropriately so this is a
picture of some normal tissue down here
sitting next to a tumor appear in the
upper left so those cells on the upper
left are growing inappropriately second
thing is that the tumor cells can crawl
out of the primary tumor
and go to other parts of the body like
the lungs of the brain or some other
part of the body and cause lots of
trouble which is actually what causes
most of the problems in cancer now to
understand something like cancer we have
to understand the basic process is
involved and the limiting factor in
dealing with cancer and every other
human disease is knowledge about the
basic biology so that's why people like
me do basic biology some of my
colleagues are here in the audience who
are also professors of biology who do
basic biology as well so this is a
little take-home message for everybody
basic science matters because we have to
understand the basic processes in our
body to understand the molecular basis
of disease you might wonder whether we
are actually prepared to answer these
questions and we weren't when I was a
student 50 years ago but we are now I'm
totally confident that the biology
community hasn't enough of the
appropriate methods that we can solve
any problem we can understand any
problem in biology including cancer and
any other disease a limiting factor is
the amount of money that society is
willing to invest in getting the answers
it's all societies willing to invest the
amount of money that we're investing now
look up the answers in decades if
society decides not to spend so much
money and I must say the current
administration is in favor of spending
less money on this then we'll get the
answer later and more people will suffer
and die it would be better if society
were to decide let's make a big push and
put more resources into this thing
because of course a little benefit all
of us and people forever
the last thing I want to say is that
science is a social activity in july--
life my people had work from me over the
years had a birthday party for me and so
here is a subset of the people who've
worked
me over the last 50 years some of them
are right here in New Haven this fellow
had Rickie dela Cruz is a professor here
at Yale this fellow and Gillian Beryl is
also a professor here at Yale these
other people are professors and journal
editors and and scientists at other
places in the world so you may have this
idea that science science is a you know
how long the activity working by
yourself in the lab but it's not it's a
social activity and one of the nice
things about a career like I've had is
to be able to work with all these
fantastic people have gone on and
expanded what we've had learned about
sells movie so thank you for coming
[Music]
we've got a raffle got some teachers to
give away we've got a great robotic camp
it goes along with looping active to
give away also if you filled up every
train to start for our Rock
[Music]
and in selling at her invunche infection
is this some hundred
okay this is Walker correct that's your
name
okay good he's got his name on his shirt
say Walker asked how the membrane
participated in the cell division
well the membranes really important
because the the ring which is going to
contract like a muscle has to be
attached to the membrane in order for
the two to bring the membrane into a
tiny little spot where the membranes
confused together allow the two cells to
separate so it's an important part of
the whole thing and actually the how how
the contractile proteins are attached to
the membrane is one of the things we
know the least about so if you want to
have a good problem to work on when you
were a scientist you could try to figure
that out there are still plenty of great
questions to be answered out here okay
this is a great question this is a
physics question about what the forces
on the node there's a lot of drag on the
node and as I just said we don't
actually understand exactly how they're
attached to the membrane but it's surely
to do with the molecules they're
attached to in the membrane we think but
we don't know for sure that there's a
really big proteins in the membrane to
which the nodes are attached okay so if
you want to pull on a node there's
actually quite a bit of drag oh like it
was I had to pull hard to move my friend
over here and that's what's resisting
the motion so if the if the pulling
stops then the node stops and doesn't
move it has to wait till it gets
captured by you know it captures another
filament and can move around that's
great up there I see a question
how did we do that oh we were horrible
to these four cells we ground them up
okay and that that's interesting because
at the time most of the people who are
interested in cell motility believes
strongly that you should not do that
okay because they had this idea they
that there was something magical about a
live cell that was required for it to
move so they figured if you ground up
the cell and killed it you kill it while
you're grinding it up that this magic
would go away and therefore you couldn't
possibly learn anything about how cells
move if you've ground up the cells as a
first step in your experiment this is a
a funny old-fashioned idea called
vitalism that there was something magic
but in fact cells are just really
complicated chemistry and physics okay
and so there's nothing magic about them
it's just really complicated chemical
and physical reactions so it is okay to
grind up the cells is the first step in
your experiment and try to get the
molecules out of the cell because when
you've got the molecules out of the cell
you can do certain you can do things
with them you can't possibly do inside
of a living cell like determine their
structures that was a great question I'm
glad you asked that there everybody
catch on to that so listen this is like
a huge change in my field and in other
areas of biology to where people have
stopped believing in magic and and now
actually believe that chemistry and
physics yes
okay that's a great question so if
you're gonna try to do this kind of work
which involves some physics and some
chemistry and some math and some biology
as well you have to have people who are
very versatile and then we do it all
inside of one lab some of the labs do it
by collaborations with another lab that
specialized for example to do
mathematical modeling well we try to do
everything inside of the one lab so all
the people can interact with each other
which may is a much more powerful that
if they're in separate rooms or in
separate buildings and so the people who
come to my lab I have a lot of different
backgrounds so for example some of them
have have been theoretical physicists
some of them have been applied
mathematicians some of them have been
physical chemists some of them have been
biologists okay and we all get together
and share our expertise to try to solve
these problems it's it's not trivial to
put together a group that can operate on
such a broad front but it's it's very
powerful if you can do it any others
yes sir I think I think one of one of
the big challenges is for the community
to take advantage of all the resources
we have available and I gave you
examples of the main resources that are
been valuable for us there are not that
many labs who take such a broad approach
to things but I'm convinced that if
everybody did that we'd all make more
progress there's always new methods
coming along and it's really hard to
predict what they're gonna be there's
some fantastic new microscopes that I
didn't tell you about the day that we
use in our lab
and they're very surprising because you
can see much finer details than anybody
would have imagined 10 years ago or 30
years ago let's let them pick a good
time 20 years ago you could not have
imagined seeing this level of detail but
some very clever physicists who won a
Nobel Prize for their work figured out
how to make a better microscope to see
finer details and so little things are
unpredictable and so oh the question is
what happened to my medical practice
okay so if you figured out I went to
medical school I don't have a PhD and so
I spent a year being a doctor and then I
got sidetracked because the fellow asked
me the question about do I really
believe there's actin and myosin and
amoebas I showed you the department
chair he offered me a chance to become a
basic scientist because he got convinced
we were on the right track and I gave up
Mike my clinical practice at that point
and became a basic scientist it was
fairly common at the time that's pretty
uncommon now but all of this has
important implications for clinical
medicine I just don't happen to do that
anymore okay thank you
[Applause]
[Music]